مَرَّ الثَّعْلَبُ فَاتْ فَات
وبِذَيْلِهِ سَبْعُ لَفَّاتْ
قَالَ اليَوْمَ سَأَخْدَعُ أَحَدًا
أَضْحَكُ أَضْحَكُ بِالسَّاعَاتْ
أَبْصَرَ عِنْدَ البِرْكَةِ أَرْنَبْ
يَصْطَادُ الأَسْمَاكَ وَيَجْذِبْ
قَالَ سَأَسْرِقُ مِنْهُ السَّمَكَة
وسَآخُذُ ذَيْلِي وسَأَهْرُبْ
خَطَفَ السَّمَكَةَ مِنْهُ وَفَرْ
وَعَلَى بَيْتِ الجَدَّةِ مَرْ
شَاهَدَ بِسْكُوتًا مَخْبُوزًا
سَاخِنا وعَلَيْهِ السُّكَّرْ
قَالَ المَاكِرُ مَا أَشْهَاهْ
بَطْنِيْ الجَائِعُ يَتَمَنَّاهْ
جَذَبَ الطَّبَقَ إِلَيْهِ بِسُرْعَةْ
وَبِلَمْحِ البَصَرِ أَخْفَاهْ
فات الثعلوب المكار
يلتفت يمينا ويسار
يبحث عن شيء يأكله
هم هم هم    هم هم
صَادَفَ أَيْضًا بِالْطُرُقَات
كَتْكُوتًا تلْعَقُ مَصَّاصَةْ
أَفْزَعَهُ المَاكِرُ بِالذَّاتْ
واسْتَهْزَأَ هَاتِي يَا صُوصَةْ
وَمَضَى يَسْخَرُ طُولَ الدَّرْبْ
لَيْسَ هُنَالِكَ شيء صَعْبْ
لَمَحَ بِكُوخٍ كُوبَ عَصِيرْ
قَالَ المَاكِرُ وَقْتَ الشُّرْبْ
رَفَعَ الكُوبَ لِكَيْ يَشْرَبَهُ
أَمْسَكَهُ بِالْحَالِ الكَلْبْ
قال له أهلا يا ماكر
مَا تَفْعَلَهُ جِدًا عَيْبْ
رَدَّ بِخَوْفٍ إِنِّي آسِفْ
أَعْتَرِفُ أَمَامَكَ بِالذَّنْبْ
اِعْطِيهِمْ كُلَّ الأَغْرَاضْ
خُذْهَا واتْرُكْنِي أَهْرُبْ